i think if i'm writing something that
feels truthful
um and sort of electric and a bit
dangerous because it feels truthful um
then i just my hope is that it will land
in the same way with other people as
well an audience makes themselves so
vulnerable and open to you when when
they're laughing when they allow you to
make them laugh that
that's when they trust you foolishly i
think the depth of knowledge of a
character is definitely
when you write it yourself
is undeniable writing for me and writing
these characters for me is like how i do
that so i write women who don't give a
[ __ ] because i'm teaching myself how to
be one i think it makes us uh feel a bit
closer to her that you see other people
um
being spiky with her and she still
continues and she still asks the
questions and she still pushes sometimes
you need to go so far away from the
thing you're making
to um to get the most um perspective and
inspiration on it as an audience myself
i just i never want to be surprised in a
truthful way not a kind of like
but i want to i want to be surprised as
much as people surprise me you know
people surprise each other all the time
it was really authentic at the beginning
and i wrote is originally a play was the
humor and the and the terms of phrases
that that particular character would
have because that's the kind of stuff
that was cracking me up at the time and
the stuff that i hadn't really seen that
much in the character and i also knew
that that's a character i wanted to play
and that he said that humor the jokes
and a lot of the kind of anecdotal stuff
i had amplified from my own life or
stuff that funny embarrassing happened
in my own life and then weaved a
dramatic story out of that that happened
to me that was embarrassing that
happened to me that was embarrassing all
on post-it notes and then crank them all
up so they were like painfully
humiliating and then found a story
within them basically trying to disarm
an audience as much as you can with
comedy and then um really punch them in
the gut with the drama
as uh when they least expect it and i
think an audience makes themselves so
vulnerable and open to you when when
they're laughing when they allow you to
make them laugh that
that's when they trust you foolishly
when i was um really
worried about not having a story for
season two and it not being as good as
season one and being i mean i was so i
mean i honestly really did try and like
back out a couple of times
and you know everyone was um
very supportive and enthusiastic and
also
would really listen to the fears of that
and uh and actually i took a lot of um
i took a lot of inspiration from how the
once how godfather then like upped its
game for godfather to i mean that sounds
sort of ludicrous but actually sometimes
you need to go so far away from the
thing you're making
to um to get the most
um perspective and inspiration on it
because if you're watching things that
are sort of similar the whole time then
you sort of feel a bit cornered and um
by style and so that was that's really
that was really helpful well what i love
about this season is that we find her at
a pretty healthy place whereas last
season i mean she's still a little a
little broken a little damaged whereas
last season she was completely destroyed
and that's where we found her and this
one she's actually doing better in a way
than everybody else
around her what do you think made that
brought the camera back why did that
bring the camera back
well i don't think it ever really went
away i just think that she um
she'd kind of uh had a different
relationship with it i think in the
first one
the pressure of the camera was that she
had a secret and the camera and she felt
like she was going to crack under the
pressure of the camera saying like
in my head it was the camera going
there's something going on with you what
is that and she's going i'm just
hilarious come into my hilarious life
there's nothing wrong with me as well
and then at the end you know there's
that relationship when she pushes the
camera away and this time i think
it was um
it came she doesn't know why it's there
this time i think last time she knew why
it was there and this time i don't think
she knows and which means she knows that
there's a journey she's going to go on
there's another thing she has to learn
about herself but this time she's not
aware of it so
so it's a different kind of relationship
for better or for worse how do you wish
you were more like your character
fleabag says what she thinks whether
it's to the camera privately or in real
life she says what she really really
thinks in the moment
and i think i'm still learning how to do
that there are so many things in the way
um like fear in the way of but also like
the more like you become in the public
sphere as well you just start checking
yourself all the time because you can
hear how people can [ __ ] with your words
and i think but so that's why writing
for me and writing these characters for
me is like how i do that so i write
women who don't give a [ __ ] because i'm
teaching myself how to be one yeah i
feel such a catharsis when i do turn to
the camera and just like say that
[ __ ] line and then ah just such an
amazing feeling why do you think fleabag
resonates with so many people i find
this question really hard to answer
because um i only know why i
uh wanted to write her and my reactions
to it as it was going out and the kind
of fire in me when i was writing it of
just what if you say this what if you do
this well i don't feel like i've seen
this perspective of
a woman's experience here like even if
it comes down to a haircut it's just
sometimes i'd be like i would love to
see that i would love to see that crime
scene i would love to see
um a miscarriage being dealt with in a
way that you know
you know i've
heard
stories in the real world um of people
having miscarriages of friends and
things and then i'd seen things on tv or
read things in fiction versions of it
and they hadn't always completely
aligned to what my friend's experiences
were and so it's that kind of thing i
think if i'm writing something that
feels truthful
um and sort of electric and a bit
dangerous because it feels truthful um
then i just my hope is that it will land
in the same way with other people as
well in the last one she's um
uh
because that sense of she's running from
something but she's hiding something so
she had to kind of be mean and be funny
to distract you from the truth and i
think this one it's again that same
thing that you that the audience know
her secrets so the relationship with the
audience is a bit more um a bit more
delicate she's a bit more there's a bit
of shame in there and there's a bit of
i don't know and working that out
actually literally looking at the camera
and working out what that relationship
was because i knew very much in the
first season it was hey come in this is
going to be fun and this one is a bit
like so you know that i'm a terrible
person and i can't come in and see see
my life and i think it makes us uh feel
a bit closer to her that you see other
people um
being spiky with her and she still
continues and she still asks the
questions and she still pushes
i mean i i don't find her unlikable at
all
and i was worried you know i was worried
that if people didn't see her pain
underneath it all and her
her
attitude was just kind of dismissive and
she just you know
didn't seem to care like she that's
clearly what she's trying to make you
think but if we were too convincing and
she just didn't care and she was just
being a dick
then i think that would justify that but
i think we were careful to build in as
much humanity as possible you know each
new writing night we'd give a brief to
the writers which were to challenge one
thing in the audience like make an
audience fall in love with the character
make an audience forgive a character of
a heinous crime or like find something
that makes an audience laugh and then
makes an audience feel sick for laughing
and we used to do these monthly and i
learned so much there about how to
surprise your audience because as an
audience myself i just i only ever want
to be surprised in a truthful way not a
kind of like
but i wanna
i wanna be surprised as much as people
surprise me you know people surprise
each other all the time and i think with
claire you know she's the one i have
most fun with really the sister
character because
the more
you think oh this is where claire would
be sort of classically anal about
something and it'd be in those moments
and i'd be like but that's where you
switch it and that's when she's actually
quite cool about something or she finds
something funny scenes jokes i have
ideas but they're just fitting them
together i think if you have enough that
you can
write them on posts and write them on
your wall and just put them together
because i think i've never thought
structure first
i've always thought material first and i
think you're the same wayfix and and
that's how we operated so much material
first jokes first character first and we
just put them all on the wall um
and then honestly just the game of what
if you put this next to this
and usually the more unusual that
pairing is with those scenes or those
scenes you put in an episode the more
interesting it it comes with it's
something something happens when you put
do you think that should be together and
then you start pulling a story out of
that this is probably really bad advice
because i know you're supposed to
structure first and then you said send
it to your commissioners and go this is
the structure of the episode
and just send like a screwed up post-it
note going out
but that that really really helped was
that was just just
knowing that you're
as long as you're enjoying writing those
scenes then then once you've got enough
then start playing with it
i think the depth of knowledge of a
character is definitely uh when you
write it yourself
is undeniable i felt when i was you know
i was in my mid to late 20s when i first
wrote the play
and it came out of a need to play
someone who was
complex and weird and had these multiple
layers and had and had a persona and
then had somebody truthful underneath
and had all that complexity but it was
also was funny and dark and sort of
sexually candid all of those things were
things i desperately wanted to play as
an
actor anyway and i'd felt the pressure
coming out of drama school to basically
be a sort of princess
um
either like a sexy princess or a not
sexy princess that was like the two
things and like and in one way or
another she's a princess you know no
matter what the story is um and so i
wanted to play someone who was a kind of
a darker version of that what has it
been like developing these two
characters with each other i mean from
the first season to this season sorry i
was so in love
oh it's been amazing sean and i have
known each other for a really long time
we were at drama school together and we
always had a fantasy of playing sisters
so to be able to do it on our own terms
as well it's been really fun because it
means every single time we have an idea
or even sometimes a little moment just
happens between us we're a bit like
going in i i don't know that i'll ever
have the kind of creative freedom that i
have with phoebe just because of the way
that we i mean we just trust each other
so much
there's so much room for failure without
embarrassment and that's
you you can't you can't get that in
another environment as writing came
along again it's really instinctual with
me and i think i feel the power of
writing something and having that
control over it and being able to author
a story and know that you're inviting an
audience in with the promise that i'm
going to take you on a journey and it's
going to be worth it and i think that is
a experience i i feel like i i might
have as an actor now if i get those
bigger roles but back when i wasn't it
was a smaller role and i didn't have
that feeling of like i want to take
people on a journey and um so that was
really driving me over the last few
years and then also writing stuff just
came along more i
obviously have to ask before we go to um
questions from the audience um i want to
ask about the fourth wall we should
always ask about the fourth wall when it
comes to um fleabag
um
the interesting part of this entire
story is that it is noticed by somebody
it is noticed by the priest who is also
himself slightly forthwalling up to god
um and uh there have been various
theories around who it is did you have
an do you have a fixed idea as to who it
is
phoebe or
um i love the idea that people can
interpret it how they like um i
it's it's as open in my mind i think as
it as it as it could be i felt like
it was
symbolic of something that i can't
really explain for me it was never a
certain person but um but i love that
for some people it is that but i feel
like it's that pressure
of being watched and feeling watched and
feeling like you're not if you're not
being witnessed does what what you're
doing count for anything does it matter
but then the flip side of that is that
if you're constantly witnessed then you
can never really
you're too frightened to um
to slip up or let someone see you be
vulnerable so she's constantly grappling
with this need for the audience to be
there to validate her and also to leave
her alone so she can experience things
on her own
um and i think that's and and for me it
was it was yeah it was it was more about
that and the same with him like
constantly questioning
you know that there's something there's
a pressure on him the whole time
asking him if he's a good person
and
for her it was that same pressure
whether that's society or boo whoever
what anyone wants it to be
it's um
it it's and it's it's a really fraught
wrought relationship um that i think
was why it was so um
important for her to be able to let it
go in the end i think in the last series
she she wasn't searching for anything
actually i think she was running from
something in the last one and it was a
constant fight to just not i don't think
she was thinking about what the future
was gonna hold i think it was just don't
let the demons from the past catch up
and and i think when people would hurt
her or she'd hurt other people it was
just you just get up and keep going to
stop it from happening she comes out
into the world fighting she wants to be
funny she wants to entertain you she
wants you to have a good time but also
she desperately wants to connect and i
feel like we can all relate to that to a
certain degree but she's still
outrageous and horny and busy and tired
you know like the rest of us
having written both comedy and drama
which do you find
easier or more enjoyable and if for the
rest of your life you could only do one
or the other which would you choose
oh no i don't think i could because i
think they're so intrinsically linked i
feel like
if there's comedy
if people are laughing they're kind of
giving you their heart a bit so
they're sort of asking you to break it
in some way i think because they're
they're it's
i don't know
i just feel like they're they're they're
too closely entwined i found it
during com when i was writing flea bag
and crashing i was like i just want
drama i hate this like on having to do a
tick thing on the page of like there's
like six jokes on this page and having
to be about generating material and
jokes was exhausting but now i'm writing
a drama i'm like i just want to put a
joke and everything's like like how do i
know if it works where's the humanity i
think finding the humanity and drama for
me is
has been
an interesting journey because i think
people being funny or jokes
reveals so much so quickly about a
character but people staring
meaningfully down a corridor
um and then walking with absolutely no
sense of humor to go and sign a form i'm
like like what's fun about that
but then but it's important so i i don't
um i don't know there is
there's a lot of humor in the drama that
i'm writing so i relate deeply really
deeply to this character she's very
personal to me and um
um i mean i mean some of the jokes and
all good situations have been lifted
from my life but i think
the the tone and the humor and the
wanting to play with the
the idea that humor covers
humor covering pain was um something
that i realized i was really familiar
with in my own life not not the same
pain that she's carrying but just kind
of letting things be funny before their
sad and um and then realizing that was
something i wanted to play with and then
building a dramatic story and so much
about character from writing and i know
a lot of actors that like will write
themselves letters from their characters
and things like that before they
actually perform and i've never been
that kind of actor but but i think it's
because because i want to write as well
but i can see that thing once you're
actually writing things down and writing
dialogue down you learn so much more
than than um
even in real life you know if you write
yourself a kind of if you just dare
yourself to write something truthful
that you think and it feels kind of
dangerous because it's like writing a
diary that you know no one's going to
look in and that's kind of what it felt
like with feedback i just thought
i'm just going to write what will make
vicky laugh was the first thing and
would make vicky feel seen and make
vicky
and having that one person in my head
was really helpful but the advice i
think is right
write as if you're not afraid
there's no reason to be afraid he just
go for it and that was the line that i
i constantly say to myself when i'm
writing and acting
you